what an amazing concept I'm always
excited about the doors on concept
vehicles but more exciting is it's been
a long time since the new Navigator came
out and it's gonna be I'm guessing a big
margin driver for you guys well it's an
important product for us it's a
navigator it's people have the highest
familiarity of Lincoln from the
Navigator name we have a very loyal
owner base and we're actually growing
our sales and actually the largest
growth in the last three years has been
in the 25 to 44 year old age so this is
the navigator concept and it gives you a
very strong indication for the new
navigator that's coming next year with
the exception of the gullwing doors
that's for the concept well we can work
on something around the doors last year
the smash hit was the Lincoln
Continental concept it's now coming out
in production form very close to what it
looked like you've invested a lot in
this brand what does Lincoln mean for
Ford Motor Company well it means a lot
when you look at the auto industry the
the luxury market around the world
that's about 10% of the total industry
but represents a third of the profits so
you know clearly it's really important
not only from a profitability standpoint
to be there but we've grown our Ford
business so much over the last five or
seven years when customers are ready to
go and move to a luxury vehicle we want
to be there for them with a great
Lincoln brand that's differentiated and
relevant versus the other competitors I
know that almost two-thirds of your
profits come from this country but
you're growing like gangbusters in China
Lincoln's a name that a lot of the
Chinese are familiar with and a lot of
the investment you're investing what
five billion dollars in Lincoln a lot of
that investments going towards opening
up dealerships in China how is the
growth there because a lot of people are
a little bit worried about whether we're
not working for a soft landing well when
you look at the Chinese economy it's
it's getting off to a good start
beginning this year the the car market
cooled off last year but we've seen some
stabilization and some growth the first
couple of months of this year so that's
good news our Lincoln brand is doing
very well we launched at the end of two
2014 we sold over 11,000 Lincoln's last
year with just two models and less than
25 dealers and that has been the fastest
growth they've seen for a luxury brand
in a long time we're gonna have 60
dealers in 50 cities by the end of this
year with a full lineup including the
new Continental that's coming there as
well so we're really encouraged by the
reception from Chinese consumers the
reception here in the US to the f-150
new f-150 was great you have sales in
Europe bouncing back South America is
still kind of crisis but overall the
industry is running hot right now are
you concerned that we are running too
hot that we are set up for a downfall
here well we think the current economic
conditions can barring any kind of
fiscal or external shock the next couple
of years can be very supportive
automotive sales and the reason we're
looking at the data we're looking at
wage growth we're looking at income
income growth we're looking at labor
growth we're looking at Sumer confidence
then we're looking at the physicals of
the business when you look at the
average age of a vehicle in the market
here in the US it's 11 and a half years
old still every year there's going to be
some replacement demand and you know
people were talking earlier this year
about recession but the data is not
telling us that if things like we've
never gone into a recession here in the
US without unemployment going up we're
not seeing that so you know we feel
pretty good about the market albeit
we're always on the lookout for any data
that's telling us differently
you have Bob Jenks in an article
yesterday talking about Ford's readiness
for any kind of downturn not that you'd
necessarily expect one but you've put
the company on much stronger financial
footing than it than it previously had
been how do you feel about your
preparedness well I think we're where we
feel pretty good about that we're gonna
continue to work on it we've gotten our
breakeven levels down here in the US to
about 11 million units so the industry
as you said the industry last year was
about 18 million units we want to make
sure that when the next downturn comes
we don't know when it's going to happen
but there's always going to be economic
cycles and business cycles that we're
ready for that we're able to stay
profitable and also maintain our
dividend that's our goal and that's what
is this concern about a downturn the
reason we don't see growth in the equity
because you know you're making almost a
billion dollars a month in pre-tax
profit the market is at an all-time high
you're taking market share and yet the
stock doesn't seem to get in well I
think there's concerns about there as
you said what's going to happen with the
marketplace concerns about China listen
we we we think our stock is undervalued
but we're not getting discouraged we
think the market is under estimating the
strength of the US market the car market
they're under estimating our record
financial performance last year our
improvement in our international
operations the the strengthening of our
balance sheet we just got upgraded again
from Moody's and S&P and underestimate
our iconic products but we're gonna just
stay very focused on the four things
that really drive shareholder value
growing our revenues expanding our
margins reducing the risk profile of the
business and continuing to afford our
shareholders all right hey Mark thanks
so much mark Fields CEO of the Ford
Motor Company introducing a new Lincoln